what I love about this movie is that
there's a really big idea at the center
of this movie and I've spoken to you a
couple of times in a few different
settings and I'm fascinated to hear you
and the other people who have made this
film talk about how so many other movies
that are out lately have these kind of
dystopian views of the future and kids
killing other kids and this really is so
different from that at what point did
you and Damon or Jeff kind of sit down
and realize let's do something that is
different from all of the other
futuristic movies that we're seeing yeah
it kind of grew out of conversations
that we all had separately and together
about what happened to the future that
we used to imagine when we were kids
the future was always brighter than the
present even though the world was not
any more of a better place than it is
now I mean there were plenty of problems
when we were kids a lot of the same
problems just in manifested in different
ways but what seemed to have changed in
the years since was a feeling that you
know the future was positive and yet we
were wondering why has that gone out of
fashion why is the only credible view of
the future negative and are we kind of
hypnotizing our selves into having it be
so you know I we never set out to give
the feeling that just put on a happy
face and lay down and be happy and great
things will happen you know dream and
fabulous things will happen you know
that's not what we're saying we're
saying that the Dreaming part is step
one of you know a journey but a journey
that is absolutely within our collective
power and I think that we thought we
could make sort of a fairy tale myth
kind of thing out of that correct me if
I'm wrong this is the fourth movie that
you've directed that you've scored
because it's ratatouille The Incredibles
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol and
this one Michael why does this
relationship work money no no
yes no that's not true you know I just
want to backtrack just for a second I
was on an airplane I was going up to
Pixar one time and Damon Lindelof who I
worked with on loss happened to also be
on my same flight you know it was just
my chance and I don't know if I ever
told you this but we were flying up
together on a Southwest plane and he
goes can you keep a secret I was like
tree because I want to show you
something I'm like well where are you
going first of all he goes I'm going to
see Brad Bird and I'm like why are you
going to see Brad Bird and and he pulled
out this thing that that book that he
made oh he brought he brought this book
which was looked like it was from the
you know the 50s or something it was
like this really old and tattered
notebook that had all of these things
and designs and ideas in it and the idea
was he created sort of a relic of a time
from when this Tomorrowland was being
built and he wanted to show that to Brad
as a way of showing him look this is
going to be a cool project please do
this with us you know so I remember that
day which was you know I told him he
goes do you think he'll do it and I said
I'm sure he this looks amazing I would
do it so you know and knowing that if he
said yes you'd probably be brought on
board yeah exactly that's my goal of
working with Damon and Brad but I think
this relationship works so well because
you know the first time I met Brad we
were up at Pixar he invited me up to
come see a little bit of the Incredibles
he had heard about me through a friend
of mine Teddy Newton who is also an
incredible animator director character
designer all of these things but he had
been working up at Pixar so I went up
there to talk to him about working on
the Incredibles and you know usually
there's a lot of like dance involved in
meeting someone new and you kind of a
lot of small talk but Brad and I
instantly fell into this conversation
about Jonny Quest we started talking
about the Flintstones we started talking
and we before you knew it it was just
like we loved all of the same things we
absolutely loved all of the same things
we talked about music we talked about
everything and most of our conversation
that day I think revolved around those
kinds of things things from arch
that we loved growing up and he got to
the point where it was like Brad you
have to actually show him the movie we
brought him up to show you cuz his
flight is going to be you know and then
and I watched it and I went back and I
wrote some music and that's a whole
nother story but I think a lot of it
comes from just our love of what we do
we both love what we do so much very
basic question here is there a different
approach from where you stand if you're
composing for an animated film versus a
live-action film no and the way I like
to look at it is you know Captain Kirk a
live-action character Star Trek that guy
is no more real than that rat who wants
to cook you know there none of its real
it's all fake they're just characters
and you have to you know there are
mediums by which to work you know you
have animation you have live-action you
have puppetry you have you know cut out
paper whatever it is those are all
mediums but storytelling is storytelling
and character is character and for me
it's all about getting into the
character regardless of the medium Brad
I know that when you guys were putting
this story together and thinking about
the Frank Walker character the idea was
to have a George Clooney type so you're
very fortunate to get him was he willing
to be bounced around and flown up to
space so soon after doing gravity you
know he read the script so I assumed
that he was ready for it yeah he he
basically said when Damon and I were
coming up the driveway he met us at his
house in LA and basically said very
nicely I don't really do these kind of
movies but if you want to pitch it what
the heck you know and we were shocked
when he was like intrigued and wanted to
go in but I think it was because of the
you know the underlying themes of the
film and the weird relationships in the
film and the fact that it's kind of a
really unusual film in usual film
clothing and
so I think that that's what drew him in
he's joked a couple times that I guess
the description of Frank Walker's you
know crusty old man and he was thought
hey wait a minute come on what are you
trying to say is that just a line that
he's said for the press tour was that
actually something he was concerned
about it didn't say crusty old man
crusty old bitter guy no it was it was I
mean the movie always started out with
him as a child and it was more somebody
who's disappointed in the future and the
future is sort of represented by the
Athena character it's really you know a
weird movie in that there's no typical
romance in it the romance is all between
the characters and the future it's not
between them as much and so I think he
was just intrigued by those ideas my
understanding is that a several of your
lead actors Britt Robertson particularly
in her first round of auditions she was
only given a handful of pages of the
script which I know was difficult for
her I obviously understand why you did
that you wanted to keep the secrecy was
it hard then to pull the trigger on some
of the big casting decisions given the
fact that these were people that hadn't
read the whole thing and weren't able to
really sink their teeth into the whole
script well we they could read it when
it was close to the final thing the
problem is you can't just go make a
movie now it especially if the budget
gets above a certain level it's like
people want to tell everyone what the
movie is and it's not like we're trying
to like we have this epic secret that
we're trying to keep it will just blow
your minds when we finally reveal it we
just don't want the story to be told
before we tell it yeah that's that's
it's as simple as that it's like I don't
want to go to Christmas and have
somebody say here's your present
it's a razor you know I want to open it
you know I want to open it and I want to
you know read the card and all that
stuff you know and and so there is this
weird you know almost hostile vibe if
you
want to keep a secret and it's not it's
not that the earth is gonna be shattered
when the secret is finally revealed you
know it's just that I just wanted us to
tell the story can we just tell the
story that be fun would it and because
when I was a kid and we saw a movie we
didn't know everything about the movie
going in we just went hey this is a
movie cool you know and so I you know
it's it's so easy everyone carries a
surprise spoiler in their pocket and you
know it becomes harder and harder to
just just have a normal movie experience